time according to greek philosopher
theophrastus
is the most valuable thing you can spend
we may want more of it but we're stuck
with the same 24-hour ward
every day of our lives beyonce's single
ladies was written in no more than 20
minutes
that's one stonking pop banger created
in less than two percent of a day
imagine what you could achieve in the
other 98
the question is how well how you think
about time can actually help you use it
more
wisely and could leave you a lot
healthier and happier
you know that rare feeling of having
plenty of time to do what you want
psychologists call it time affluence and
it does
a lot for your sense of well-being
bizarre
as it may sound it's possible to make
yourself feel more
time-rich by handing over some of your
r's to others
one study took a large group of people
some of them helped others in their
spare time
doing things like writing letters to
cheer up a sick child
while the rest did whatever they liked
the helpers later felt
they generally had more free time
compared to the rest of the group
despite giving some of it away so rather
than binging on that box set
do something for someone else you'll end
up feeling it's possible to achieve more
in the time you have
9. think about all those tiny chunks of
your day when your brain isn't doing
very much
at all like going for a run sitting on a
bus
or making a cup of tea scott hits young
author of ultra learning specializes in
making time work better for people
he sees these mini down times as chunks
of opportunity
to use more wisely so how do you want to
use that time
you could try productive meditation
if something is turning out to be a
pretty naughty problem
use your daily jog to focus your mind on
your surroundings
and your subconscious may find a
solution while your mind relaxes
or while the cattle boils listen to the
sound of the water
watch steam rising from the spout be
truly
mindful and in the moment evidence
suggests that when you get back to your
desk
you'll get a lot more done than the time
you have start creating habits
young says you'll be surprised how much
materializes once you simply start doing
things
for a few minutes a day whatever route
you take bear in mind that several
recent studies
have shown that trying to fit more in by
working longer hours
can lead to stress and illness and
nobody wants that
psychologist claudia hammond suggests
that the best way to make free time feel
worthwhile
is to indulge in the holiday paradox
this says that doing something new sees
your brain make an extra effort to
remember it
so vary your routine try new hobbies
different experiences however small will
be more rewarding
and when you're looking back on them
your sense of time will be expanded
did you realize that if you add up sleep
very important
eating and working most of us have
around five
hours a day left to do what we want to
do
so take advantage of it you could even
write a fifth of a novel
john boyne wrote the boy in the striped
pajamas in just two and a half
days not sure how much sleep he got
though or you could climb to the top of
ben nevis in five hours
if it was a weekend you might have time
to get down again
but don't be too hard on yourself if you
just need that time
to chill a study in 2010 showed that
playing computer games or watching tv
can restore us emotionally and help us
recover intellectually
after a hard day but you've got to buy
into the experience
totally and don't feel guilty isn't that
a relief